No. Apparently transcription has
started itself. Hello everyone.
Welcome to yet another
Visual C Open code review.
I'm Casey Carter.
Remember the library's team here?
I spent a lot of time working on
the SCL and quite a bit of time
working on standardization with
WG 21 of the actual C + + 9.
Today we're going to be talking about.
PR2580 for the STL,
which is implementing P2440R1 ranges.
Iota Rangers shift left
and ranges shift right.
I'm gonna pull up the paper real
quick since I didn't do that yet.
Ohh no. Sorry I don't have my
shortcuts configured correctly here.
No, this is a relatively short paper.
Adding you are not yet sharing your screen,
by the way, not yet sharing my screen.
Thank you.
OK. This is the paper of P2440R1.
It adds 3 new ranges algorithms.
The things that were already
existing algorithms in pre ranges,
world right? IOTA exists,
except it's not in the algorithms header,
it's in the numerics header.
But it's nonetheless an algorithm.
This adds Iota shift left and shift right.
As a Rangers algorithms,
in addition to their
stood algorithm versions.
So what's get the PR?
In the paper. Side by side.
We'll go into the files here.
Alright, in my usual alt click
trick to compress everything down
and wow this is touching a lot of
files for adding three algorithms.
We've got a new test for each.
Test case. And configurations for
test test test configuration.
I was going to change the future test macro,
presumably because this paper
adds a future test marker that
will not need to test for.
Changes to core,
probably to show that the
paper has been implemented.
Interesting, did we add just iota
in the numeric header? Must have.
Let's do to me. I thought we were
gonna have them on algorithms.
But I was apparently wrong.
Yeah, even says the feature test marker
is in in numeric. Alright, awesome.
It's more fun to discover these
things as we go than to read
the paper had a time right so?
And we know why that's changing
all of these headers.
Let's, uh, start from the top.
Let's make sure the new tests are in here.
And that the names are spelled correctly.
This is a. The shift left test.
And both of its files are there.
Shift right? Ohh
I know this is a change to the.
Existing shift right test.
Now I'm very confused why we're.
Choosing the existing test
and adding a new test.
But we'll work that out when we get to it.
Addition is actually correct.
The correctly spelled name,
and that's all I'm concerned about right now.
Again, these three new tests
have been added and the spelling
of the names is correct.
We actually have to double check that
because otherwise we are test automation
isn't bright enough to tell us.
If the names are spelled correctly,
it will just run those tests and be happy.
Next step, let's pop into rivals core.
Yeah, there's the addition of
the comment that says we've
implemented this proposal.
It is in sorted order.
I'm not sure if the name matches.
#2537 the the name in our issue,
we're usually really.
Sticklers about.
Using a simplified name.
This simplified titles for papers
that are easier to keep track of.
That's not the right one.
537 OK. The transposition.
Yep, that's exactly the title we
listed it with in our issue for the
proposal. So that's all correct.
Looks like we have pulled CPP
Lib shift out of the C + + 17.
Section of future test macros.
Probably to move it down to
the conditional section.
Make this bigger.
Too many comments.
23 section now that we've
got this in the wrong place.
Apparently Stephen has already
commented that this is the wrong place.
It needs to move down to
the macros with language,
but it's to be section we have.
Four different sections of
feature test macros we defined
here that are C + + 17 macros.
These that are defined in 20
things that were defined in 23.
Whenever the macro depends on language
mode or pretty much anything else,
it gets pulled out and goes into a fourth
section for the whatever configurable things.
And just needs to go there,
but isn't yet so.
That's already noted,
we don't need our notice again.
We'll make sure that the value is right.
Yeah, it's 2020 202,
which is the February.
Eating,
I'll check that in there.
Enter that I continually have that we're
working dress open for. CP Lib shift.
Is in fact defined to 2022 or two?
So this was added in February.
We've got into comments that
matches correctly matches the.
Condition on but if so, that's all good.
Addition of the new feature
test macro for CP web ranges,
IOTA. This is out of order.
It was added to the end of this
section instead of being added
into this section and sorted order,
which would put it somewhere up here.
In between invoking this snooping on
Stefan has already commented on that.
It should actually move up just one because
it's CP live ranges iota. Thank you.
Luckily I didn't commodate incorrectly
and I don't have to fix it.
Anyway, we're we have feature test macros.
That's presumably all the things
that were defined by the paper.
I don't understand why people
can't put the feature test macro
wording in the right order.
Like you never do.
Objective value CPP Lib
shift inversion not sin.
Find CPP library just like iota.
Those are all the features
test macros, so this header.
I said everything correct?
There's nothing additional to
comment on in this area. They're all.
Still on common ground.
Moving on. Let's do product code.
I'm going to look at X
utility first because it's a.
A higher order header than algorithm
in America that users include, right?
This is an internal header.
And this one happens to be included
by both algorithm and numeric,
so I assume there's a common code in here.
And this is adding the out value
result algorithm result type.
There are a whole bunch of these things
that we call result types whose names
all in with under score results that
were added to be types with pretty user.
Respectable names for the return
values of the ranges algorithms
because we wanted to avoid ever
having anything return tuple or pair,
we wanted to always return names
types with named members that people
would refer to that would be stable.
Because it's very hard when you're
writing fresh code that takes.
A pair, right? If you're using,
say, insert into stood map.
Returns a pair of an iterator and a bowl,
and people can never remember if it's an
iterator in a bowl or bowl and an iterator,
so having actual names you can see
you don't have to remember the order.
Anyway, this is called out value result,
which means it's going to
have a member named out.
I don't remember a named value.
We have a very very simple.
Naming rule that temperature
21 uses for these types.
Uh, these are gonna have no
unique address applied to them,
which is a pretty much a good
idea with anything generic.
In C + + 1 E, I'm going to go find.
Here's the declaration of this fast template.
It's supposed to be instant ranges.
Make sure we're within ranges, yes?
Within ranges we're in the concept section.
This is being made
conditional for SQL plus 23.
Which is all correct.
There's the indef there's commentary.
It doesn't match.
The detailed specification of
this and I didn't want to click
that that's going to link.
Yeah, you got the standard.
Alright, detailed spec.
This is again a class with two parameters.
The members are both there.
They're types are the first parameter.
The first template argument and the
first second template arguments.
There no unique address.
Appropriately,
we are leaving these commented out.
In the STL, for now,
because MSVC didn't support no
unique address for a very long time,
and what we did do was add the
attribute to the compiler so the
compiler understood the attribute
and didn't do anything with it.
And then by the time it came,
you know,
by the time we decided we needed
to actually implement the
semantics of the attribute.
It became clear that doing so
would be an ABI break because
we had been compiling code,
they had that attribute in it already
for a couple of point releases and
not doing anything with the attribute.
Since we really,
really don't like Breaking API,
that meant we decided to
have no unique address.
Do nothing in MSVC until the next ABI break.
We do have another attribute
that's in the MSVC namespace.
It's MSVC colon colon.
No unique address,
which does do the IT does have the
semantic effect that the standard
specifies for no unique address,
right?
There are no backwards compatibility
concerns because we added that
with the semantic in place right
when that attribute was new,
but unfortunately that means we still
can't use no unique address even
with the MSBC specific attribute.
In the STL,
because client doesn't support it yet.
And Clang largely doesn't support it yet,
because they're waiting on me to get
information to them about exactly
how our implementation works,
and I haven't had time to do that lately.
So for now we have no unique
address with comments and many
places in our header files.
Is there a reminder that eventually?
There needs to be a, you know,
unique address there.
Or the equivalent.
OK, again, this is result type.
They have the standard format they
have named fields in a struct.
And they should be convertible to
other specializations of the same
class template when the types of
the members are convertible from the
types used in this specialization to
the types in another specialization.
So here is a conversion operator to.
How how value result with?
Ohh out and tie 2. Interesting.
I would expect to use the same convention
either adding two to both of the names.
Or doubling the character at the beginning
I I wouldn't care about a convention,
but it's kind of strange that we picked
two different conventions for naming these,
so I wanna comment on that.
It's OK. That you're using.
To.
Name? Adjustment.
Name Justin conventions?
To get the parameter name,
it's for the conversion operators.
Please pick one.
I'm going to go ahead and edit this point.
I thought it applies to both.
Looking at other examples in the STL,
it does appear that the repeated character
is the current convention. We've got
INOLF fun.
Wonder if to tie was a problem.
Can't imagine what it would be.
Interestingly, for like minmax
result we do use tie two,
so there's Preston for both,
just not in the same.
Actually, maybe there is one I.
I haven't completely searched thoroughly yet.
Now we. Give this is his consistency
as the hard ground on the small minds.
They think it's villains.
Anyway, we'll we'll work that out.
Alright, so it's a conversion operator.
It is correctly constrained to require.
That the target type O is convertible
from a constant value out,
and that's gonna be constant value
because this is a constant L value
qualified conversion operator.
And. Same for the other type.
That cost tiraf is convertible.
Sorry, the Type 2 is convertible from Tyra.
Any little helper concept?
And of course,
it just has to return.
Members
yes, this is an aggregate.
It's not not. It's an aggregate.
We don't need to worry
about explicit conversions.
So so it doesn't need,
and it's hard to type.
And the other one.
This is going to be the R
value converting constructor.
Yep, our our value qualified.
And we require that. Our value out.
Sorry an X value out I guess.
Right that out is convertible
from and out X value.
The reference here is extraneous.
This is one of those things that we
like to harp on a lot in the code with
type traits and or concepts that use.
Deco Val, the central.
In their implementation the T ref ref
is the same as T and is equivalent.
And we try to keep the excess rest the sorry,
the extraneous refs out of the code,
because it's just a little more
garbage to read and decipher.
Someone has already commented
this so I won't comment it again.
Thank you miss go.
You're catching that.
Otherwise, this is a.
Constexpr conversion operator to out value.
Result of those types of once again.
We're returning, you know,
the difference here being that
we're moving these members to
get conversions from our values.
Which is consistent with the R value
qualification of the conversion operator,
all good.
So this is matching the pattern
that we use elsewhere for.
A great many algorithm result types.
And that's the only change
we have here in the utility.
Personally, that's gonna be used
in at least one or two of these.
It's also possible that they
just put it in the header.
No, he's our founding results.
Sorry, I'm going to scan through quickly.
No, these return subrange.
So it's actually only gonna be used.
In numeric.
But presumably someday we might have
another algorithm that needs it,
and it might make sense for it to be an
X utility instead of pushing it down and.
Ohh, it looks like we lost Casey.
Lego Pokémon. OK, maybe his teams crashed.
Please stand by.
Hello, welcome to another another.
Visual C++ Open code review.
OK, where was that when I disconnected?
You were talking about potentially
moving something to find an X
utility down to the header.
It's used or whether it should be kept
in the central header for potential
future use right out value results.
This lvalue result apparently is
only used in America right now.
We could put it in America instead
of putting it in next utility.
I'm tempted to leave it in next utility
because that's where the majority,
if not all.
Of the other algorithm,
result types are defined.
Yeah, they did put this. Together with.
Other algorithm result types in the header.
You might want to reshare your screen.
Are they different? Apparently
I didn't do it hard enough.
There we go. Yeah, right?
OK.
Tiny little through product cost. Or one
class template that's not instantiated?
I don't see this being a
huge throughput problem.
If we do leave it in next utility,
so I'm not gonna complain about it.
But then again, I've.
I wouldn't refuse to change if somebody
else said they wanted one either,
so I'm just gonna let that one go for now.
And we're going to move
on to more product code.
We've been doing to numeric.
And take a look at IOTA.
OK, I need a little more context to
see where we are in the header where
right after stud iota. Excellent,
that's where I would want this to be.
Right off the bat,
we're defining the alias for the result type.
This again is also part of the
Convention used for ranges algorithms.
We'll have a result type
called a generic result type.
It's name is exactly the same as the
names of its members member name,
member name, etcetera under score
result and then we'll have a
specific alias for each algorithm
for the result type that it returns.
Since this algorithm is named Biota.
Have IOTA under score result.
Is an alias of out value result and that
again is exactly as specified in the.
Moving on, this is internal machinery.
I'd like to get down to see the.
Actual user public declarations first.
Make sure that they match
the standard OK. You have.
Input or output iterator.
Sentinel for that input or output
iterator and weekly increment table.
Requires indirectly writable.
First type comma,
constant value of third type.
Those that agrees.
Constexpr I order results.
First parameter, third parameter.
Iota, the Silverload takes
an iterator and a Sentinel.
And another type initial value.
So this does appear. Exactly.
Like the declaration in the paper.
And this next one also.
Full output range. It's.
No value of first parameter type.
Context for returns of iota result
of borrowed iterator. R comma T.
Party radar augmentee iota.
A forwarding reference to RNG.
Each type and value.
So these declarations do look
exactly like they do in the paper,
which means they are wrong.
Yes, this is one of these weird
things we have frontmatter.
For ranges out of the rooms.
That specifies.
You get the standard open.
Which I lost somewhere here.
And while you find that I'll read out
Cameron's question, Cameron asks,
I have a question unrelated to this
specific PR rather ranges as a whole.
I notice that some algorithms like for
each are not available for ADL to find.
That's argument dependent lookup because
they're implemented as an inline variable.
But others, like this iota are not.
What is the motivation for
one method versus the other?
What is strangely pertinent question.
So. The reason for the difference is
that these in the PR are incorrect.
We have front matter that states
various requirements for, uh,
overloads of algorithms and ranges.
Hmm, this is the right stuff I will find.
Parameters otherwise specified.
There we go. The entity is defined
as the stood ranges namespace.
Let's make this bigger.
So that I'm not the only one
who can see what I'm reading.
OK, look at paragraph 2 here in
algorithms that requirements the
new disappointing the stood ranges
namespace in this clause are not found
by argument dependent name lookup.
When found by unqualified name lookup.
Or the postfix expression and the
function call basically unqualified
lookup or a function call.
They inhibit argument dependent lookup.
This is an intentional bit of
design weirdness where we had to
introduce this property so that.
Calls to ranges algorithms would be
unambiguous and they wouldn't be actually.
Only ambiguous isn't the problem.
If you think about calling find,
for example the the the two
iterator version of find. And stood.
Has a corresponding iterator Sentinel
implementation to find and ranges.
And if you wanted to call
find with two iterators.
And those two were somehow
in the same lookup set.
You would end up calling the stud version.
Instead of the ranges version,
because it is more specialized
since stood behind,
takes two first arguments by the same
type and the Ranges 1 takes those two
arguments could be different types.
It is less specialized. Anyway,
and in order to get around this problem,
we decided to make the range of things
not findable by ADL and inhibit
ADL when they are found otherwise.
So that these calls will work.
And of course,
implementing that means we have to
implement them currently as objects.
It would be nice if C++ gave us
a better tool so that we could
go ahead and actually implement
these things as function tippets,
but function templates that have
the same property of inhibiting ADL
or not being fined found by ADL.
But that hasn't happened.
There are proposals in the works.
In the standard, but none of them,
to my knowledge, is actually progressing.
So that's the thing,
we have lots of things that are not really
specified as objects that are amplified,
implemented as objects in the STL.
For ranges algorithms, they're often
referred to colloquially as diploids.
Thanks to Tips Song who is a
CPP reference maintainer and.
Occasionally shows up at W 21.
He came up with this name Niblets
to basically mock Eric Niebler.
Since Eric wanted them to be objects,
and I argued that we should probably
force the language to make functions
work so that libraries could use
functions instead of having to
have everything be an object.
Anyway, until that day comes,
that means these things have
to be implemented.
As sort of object likes.
We have a convenient pattern we
use for that in the STL already.
Go into algorithm here.
While you're looking that up,
I have a question.
So in the the standard there's
been some movement towards trying
to name things by what they are
rather than after people because the
people based names are confusing
like argument dependent lookup,
occasionally used to be called
Koenig lookup after Andrew Koenig
who was the one who specified it,
but Connick lookup tells you
nothing unless you know who
he was and what he did and.
Argument tip dependent look up at least
says what it does with the knee fluids.
Is there a formal term
that we should be using?
I know that customization point
object is related but different
and I can never remember if.
Yeah, and people get the two things mixed
up all the time because one of them
has a name and the other one doesn't.
And because we added both things in
ranges at the same time to the standard,
so a customization point object is
something that is explicitly an object.
Right, it's a call.
It's callable it's a function object type.
But it is definitely an object you're
allowed to treat it like an object,
which means you can pass them around as
arguments to things that take function,
or do that that take function
object arguments,
which of course is extremely handy,
and it would be really handy to have
for the rest of these algorithms.
But again,
since I would like the core language to
be usable by people who write libraries.
I I would like if we had first
class overload sets or.
Overloads of function templates
and we didn't need to make again,
we didn't have to artificially
force things to the objects so
that they would be useful.
So it would probably be nice if
we had a name for this thing,
especially if it's gonna stick
around for much longer. Umm?
I think maybe in one or two more cycles
of the standard at most will either
have changes in the core language
that let us use all these things,
actual function templates,
but function templates with an attribute.
All of them that gives
them the right semantics,
or we'll have given up,
and these will become.
Actual explicit objects,
in which case they'll just be Cpos.
Like the other Cpos.
And we won't need a name for neighborhoods.
Anyway, the the transient,
the intended transient nature is why we
never had a name for it in the 1st place.
We just called.
Let them be things and somebody had
to decided to come up with the name.
The document that right Tim is a I
said he was a CPP reference maintainer
and he came up with a name to be able
to document these things as a class.
Thanks, that explains a lot and I've
been reviewing this for a couple
of years now and I didn't know the
whole story. Well, now you do.
I also have a question about these
things, uh, which might be.
Unrelated, and if it is,
you know we can talk about it later, but.
How do you get a function
pointer to these things?
Because I don't see in the
standard that you can't take a
function pointer to these things,
but I don't see how it's implemented
to take a function pointer.
Sorry it's not implemented because
you're not allowed to take the
address of things and namespace
stood except when explicitly allowed.
Ah. Friends, another one of the
changes that came there in C + + 20.
Yeah, we we have algorithm requirements
and or blanket requirements that
have just enough magic to let you
implement these things as functions.
I'm sorry as objects.
Despite him being depicted as
function tablets in the iOS.
Cool, we for example we have working
this issue can't pass explicit
template argument list to these.
Because that would break if it was
an object and not actually a temple.
Anyway, there, and it's worth noting.
It's a it's worth noting that users
taking the address of standard library
functions or passing explicit template
arguments to them was problematic even
before these object imitators were added.
For example, people doing that with
stood make pair back in C + 9803.
We're broken when the signature
of make pair changed in C + +
11 to be perfect forwarding.
It would create a totally you know,
undesirable templates specialization.
If you said make pair angle bracket you know
int comma double you would now get int,
ref, ref, comma,
double ref ref as your function parameters
and that is not something that code
written in C + 9803 was expecting so it
had always been problematic and with the
addition of these object like things,
the standard flatly forbidding users from
doing this unless otherwise specified
has solved both those problems and more.
Yes, and for Britain take.
The admissions has also conveniently
allowed us Tom and make some more
optimizations to the STL that
we couldn't do otherwise.
Starting to call,
I think I interrupted you.
Ohh I was just saying thank
you for the explanation. Yeah.
That's what this process is all about.
So anyway, here's an example of fine.
First of the implementation of
the find first of algorithm,
it is defined as a again a class object,
and we have a helper called not quite object
that we derive these from whose purpose.
Is to make impossible.
Some of the behaviors that you
would expect to work with this if
it was supposed to be an object
to keep people from accidentally
taking advantage of what's
effectively implementation details.
So not quite object.
He's gonna find that.
It's got to be an X utility, right?
And, uh, here we go. Not quite object.
Actually describes its what its purpose is.
Because this is a really weird thing.
It has deleted default constructor to keep
you from constructing objects of this type
without knowing the magic construct tag.
For example, right, we have a secret tag
type that's necessary to construct these.
They're not copyable or movable,
and we've even deleted
the address of operator.
You can't try and take the address
of it like it's an object.
And. Ohh protected,
default protected destructor always
a nice thing with the base class to
have either a virtual or a protected
destructor to keep people from
destroying through pointers to base.
With the undefined behavior.
So this is designed to be a base class
and it inhibits lots of otherwise
useful things that you would want
to have your objects to have if
they were intentionally objects.
So these to the two template
overloads of IOTA.
There are only two right, yes?
Did only bloyd
sorry. I'm scanning the existing comments.
It looks like we actually have an an attempt.
Let's clarify this a little bit. Verifying
the algorithms.
I think did you look at miss who's first?
Comment because I think in his
first comment he did at least try
to explain what he Bloods are.
This is the this is the second occurrence,
that's why he just said Ditto.
Yes, I get that and.
Let's look just search for me, boy.
So now this is unfortunately in ranges.
Algorithms are not functions
or function templates.
But our currently implemented as diploids
as our objects with the call operator.
The reason for that is that it inhibits BDL.
Close enough.
There are some conventions to follow here,
and you should have a look at how the
other Ranger charms are implemented.
The general starting point is something like.
Class. Algorithm name under score fondness.
That's how we name them all consistently.
Name under score fund.
Hear it privately from not quite object.
Make its constructor set available
without using declaration.
Then implement.
Overloads of the function call operator
to implement your actual algorithm.
Declare an inline variable.
Object of that type.
The type of your function object.
And initialize it with not quite
an object secret construct tag.
So. This is a great comment.
I think he actually did a pretty good
job of explaining what to do here, yeah?
Which I just wanted to save you the work
of writing all that again from scratch.
Yeah, Moscow has implemented quite a
few ranges algorithms in his time,
so I I'm not at all surprised that
he knows how to do it correctly.
Anyway, that's awesome. You know this.
It's fun having a community.
Or around the SCL to do our work for us.
Alright, coming back here so that
that's already clear, right?
Uh, did Arnie Boyd?
Presumably they will understand if
they read Miscoe comments in order.
What that is trying to tell them?
So we will go ahead and review the algorithm.
See what the paper had to say.
Paper, which I've lost track of.
Of the following effects equivalent too.
Our first is not equal to last.
Well, first not equal to last.
Start first equals as constant value.
We are as consisting the value to
enforce the value doesn't get modified.
Which I don't think stood Iota does,
but hey, that's OK.
It's still pretty close.
We increment the iterator.
We increment the value.
Move one around until we
get to see the range,
and then we return the final
value of the iterator and
the final value of the.
Object that we're using to
initialize things. Pick your name.
Accumulator would be the name if it was.
Uh. Stood accumulate, but it isn't so.
Accumulator is nevertheless what it's doing.
And let's go see what the
actual implementation does.
Is this going to be hard to read?
It's a shame there's no
way to collapse. Comets.
GitHub that would be really nice.
Anyway. Let's look at the
iterator central overload first.
We've already checked.
The signature is correct.
He the first step is to verify.
The iterator signal range using our
iterator checking machinery we have.
This is a standard video verify
range doesn't look up to figure out
if these iterators are iterator in
Sentinel type are opting into our
iterator checking machinery and it's
so it does any checking necessary.
After which it's safe for us to unwrap the
iterator types into an unchecked type.
Let's the STL use checked iterators and
still have it allows the STL to use
checked iterators in APIs so that we
can ensure users are using the errors
correctly and then unwrap them and have fast,
unchecked iterators that we use internally
for the actual implementations of algorithms.
In any case, we're verifying the
range and then we're going to unwrap.
Those first and last.
Since this is.
Potentially input iterator.
Yeah, this is potentially
a single pass iterator.
We have to pass in our
value to get unwrapped.
Since input errors may have
things that need to be moved.
So we are wrapping our value.
We unwrapping our value of the Sentinel.
We'll pass all of this to.
The helper ioda unchecked,
which is a common name that we use.
For helpers that implement the algorithm.
After the unwrapping.
Right there,
using unchecked iterators
instead of checked iterators.
And I haven't checked his up here.
It takes an iterator.
Constant reference to the santone.
Instead of taking the central value.
That's kind of odd.
That was already accommodated
here on the thing that I'm
calling out as being kind of odd.
I don't know if this is a different
thing, sorry. This was common,
suggesting that we could take Valve
by constant reference instead of by
mutable reference, which doesn't work.
As Stephen has already pointed
out here. And I'm gonna go
ahead and resolve this comment.
Just to draw attention to the to the fact
that there's no action to be taken here.
So the the author of the of the PR can
read the comments that they like to,
but they will hopefully know that
they don't need to do anything.
Here's the body we're using that
for loop instead of a while loop.
First, not equal to last increment.
First increment Val.
It's got the mandatory
mandatory voting cast here.
Which hopefully keeps, uh,
overloaded comma operators from being called.
As always in the STL, we have to
defend against hijacking of operators
that we use by strange ADL overloads.
Right, this algorithm is not.
Specified as calling uh comma
operator with an iterator and this
whenever object type we're passed in,
so we can't observably call that operator.
We have to make sure that.
It's not observable by user,
and we do that by basically ensuring
that no ideal lookup will find
an operator comma and invoke it.
The built-in operator comma.
All right,
and we've got a start first equals.
Comcast.
This is a handy way of implementing,
as columnist directly.
Instead of calling as constant.
I would, uh,
make the argument here that it
should probably use static cast.
Umm?
Because that's yeah.
So we're we're not casting away consent,
so we I, in my opinion,
should be suggestion to actually
call stood as Constance dead.
I don't think that's a great idea either.
I think we can get away
with the static cast here.
And I have offered a third alternative
because and you can read my comment there.
Static cast is powerful in a different way.
It can't remove Constness but
it's willing to, you know,
make temporaries and that sort of thing.
Or maybe not temporaries,
but it's willing to do fairly
powerful transformations.
So here we want something
that happens implicitly,
so if we're willing to spend an extra line,
we could just implicitly
bind a constant type ref.
I think that would probably
be safer than a cast,
or at least less scary looking.
Interesting. Yeah, because the the
thing about static cast is it's willing
to reverse implicit conversions,
which is actually what we don't want here.
We want the forward implicit
conversion of adding constants,
but there's no like super safe
static cast that'll do just that.
So that's why I suggest.
Just make a temporary variable
or a local variable.
I wouldn't send out of this.
I wouldn't write this.
I would write it to start,
I would write the static cast I.
I wonder why it matters to me.
It's interesting.
I would write the static as probably
cause this consumes an extra line.
There's another name to reason about.
We avoid that with the cast.
It is unfortunate that there's
no clean cast that just says add
costs to this other than the one.
Of course that we define
the standard library.
Which requires instantiating a function
template and suffer the throughput cost.
So yeah, I will.
I'm happy with this,
I'm I'm not gonna add another
comment here just to be clear.
One thing I will say is, uh,
something that is confusing to me is
why we are not OK with as contst.
But are OK with move.
Because that that.
Seems odd to me.
Not really OK with move either. Yeah,
you gotta, that's it's an excellent point.
Like we we do spend move, oh sorry go
ahead the the the cognitive overhead
of implementing move directly is high.
And that that's really the issue,
it's it's much more readable to see stood
moved blah than it is see static cast.
Ex ref ref blah and then have to go back
and determine OK is X actually the type?
This move, or is it forward or
is it doing something else?
And in that sense,
having the actual names moving forward
as vocabularies is nice for readers.
Fair enough, that said,
there is a throughput cost and
it would be nice if we didn't
have to pay the throughput cost.
You know, I could be convinced that we
should have forward and move macros.
Even though I despise macros,
I could be talked into it as a way to
improve throughput. If I I would be,
I would be interested in the like.
Amount of actual speed you'd get from
switching to moving forward macros. Uh.
Especially since move, I think you still
need to instantiate, remove, remove rafty.
This is the template, I don't know.
Anyway, beside the point and we have we,
we have active conversations with the
front end team about making at least
forward and move compiler known so that
it can just directly transform them
without emitting real function calls for
reference claiming and I believe Jesus.
We have already done so,
and MSVC does similar things to things
like remove CVT just not moving forward,
so that's that would be my preference
compared to macros. Honestly,
I mean now looking at my comment here,
it sounds like I'm advocating that
we shouldn't use as constant.
I'm actually fine with mascons here.
I mean, it is one call per element,
which is a little bit more expensive than
one call per outer call to the function.
I had just recommended ohh you know
we could use a local variable here in
case you know throughput was a concern
because I know that I personally have
been relatively unconcerned about debug.
Performance over the years and I should
probably care a little bit more,
and this seemed like a reasonably
cheap way to do so that didn't involve
like obnoxious static cast ref.
Ref or anything,
but I would be fine with as constant myself.
Also, this is totally gross and I hate it,
but you could put the constant tie ref
constant Val equals Val above the loop.
Uh. Yeah.
Which would result in keep it bound
even though the value changes, yeah.
Yeah, that it. It still spends a line.
I don't think it would necessarily
interfere with compiler optimizations,
but it is weird to reason about.
It would be one you wouldn't have to
skip over every time you're going
through the loop and single step mode.
There there were, they that improvement,
yeah? A little bit of UX.
If you're debugging through this, but.
Yeah, we can argue there's lots of reasons.
Lots of little reasons to prefer
one thing or another thing I.
I don't think any of them is
actually the best suggestion.
Sorry I don't think any of them is
clearly better than the others.
Except of course getting rid of Comcast.
I think we all agree.
If we don't like the Comcast,
no constest everywhere, please God.
Well, we we do have some Comcast
in the code base I believe,
but keeping them to where they're
necessary is like really unavoidable is
ideal because that way we can focus all
of our attention on them and say, OK,
we're doing something super scary here.
Let's make really sure that
this is the right thing to do.
Which is generally true for cast,
but especially for Comcast.
It really seems like we should
have this like unsafe keyword.
Maybe that puts all of our focus
on unsafely into like 1 area maybe.
We already have one.
We have a lot of them.
We have as many unsafe keywords
as you like in C++. That's one
one advantage he has over us.
Advantage OK. Moving on.
I think we've beaten this
point into the ground.
We've got this loop.
We're happy that the loop is correct.
You don't like the Comcast?
We've made recommendations about
putting something different there.
Umm? I don't think we need this move.
1st. Is the name of a variable with
automatic storage duration. Right?
Does that mean that gets UM get the metric
or value treatment and return right? Yep.
They they added that though after 11.
I think that's why I missed it because
in 11 original the function parameters I
think were not eligible for auto moving
and that did change at some point.
All the standard versions blur
together for me now. Umm?
Right, because function parameters cannot be.
Like nerve out like they can't be like
done without they they can't be RVL
you can't do return value optimization
because the parameter has to get
stored parameters go like can't get
stored whether returned by goes.
But nevertheless, I think the
implicit move rule. Works here,
so we don't really need this move.
And I think Nicole was correct
to say Nervo specifically
because it is a named parameter.
Although now return value optimization
is not a thing in C because PR
values are actually a real thing,
I'm so happy they finally fixed that.
There we go. First, I copied our vision 1.1.
What is extraneous?
Looking at this makes me wonder
if this is potentially a global
problem throughout the code base,
like if we're redundantly moving
parameters that are non CV qualified.
I bet you there's other currencies,
not that we would ask this contributor
to go clean up things globally.
If anything, it should be a separate PR.
Should do a global global thing for this.
I'm not terribly concerned because
it's not really a throughput issue.
Redundant move is only a
problem when it inhibits.
Ohh that's right, yeah, yeah can't dribble.
So it most. It's in the extra call
so it's just extra words to look at.
Yeah is the is the believe.
I, I believe that this should be paragraph 3.
Uh. Paragraph 1.1 is about are
named return value optimization.
So, uh.
In return statement,
when the expression is the name
of a non volatile object with
automatic storage duration
other than a function parameter,
the copy move operation can be emitted.
Throw protein exception declaration.
And implicitly movable entity.
The sporting got changed. Recently for 23.
More things became implicitly movable.
On my storage duration that's known,
while another reference to
a nonvolatile undertype OK.
So they haven't broken this wording.
It's still 3 and 3.1 specifically.
And I do recommend citing a working
paper number when you cite a paragraph,
particularly when they are
editing the the standard's.
There's paragraph numbers can be
moved around, as we've seen here,
so saying like in 4910 if that's
the latest one could be helpful.
If we got to go look this up,
you know in five years and wonder,
wait what we're what we're reciting,
what paragraph with the was this?
Should this use? Tim Song C PWP.
So that it's stable.
That's a really good idea.
Don't remember.
What no 4910?
Attack the. I didn't see a tip of trunk,
but I don't know which that corresponds to.
I haven't. I haven't used this myself.
I was just proposing citing the actual just
name to say 4910 and let them look up.
Look it up necessary because mostly
concerned about us looking at this comment.
The problem for years down the road
right now I have to go look at 4910.
Because I never used the working,
I never used the working draft I always use.
My own copy. That I regenerate every day.
All right, where were we? Class dots copy.
Alright, there we go.
It's paragraph 3. In in 4868.
It probably also isn't in 4910.
Yeah, as long as it hasn't changed recently,
most time I was just suggesting citing a
specific graph so that if we ever needed
to look this up later, we could find
exactly which paragraph we meant. So.
1st is.
Alright, moving on.
Next overload you know this is
the overload we're working on.
Still sorry, this again returns the final
value of the iterator from the loop.
We don't need to return the final
value of Val because we're using.
An elevator that references the original
value of the owl in the car today.
There so. We get first back
from this iota unchecked call.
It's an R value, so we don't need to move it.
We wrap it back up inside.
The original iterator.
Which we then return.
In our out result.
Alright results.
IT comma Thai we're returning.
There's lots of moving 1st and tie,
and the paper did want us to move.
Tie. Didn't it?
Return move first move value.
The other other overload for ranges.
This takes an iota.
It takes a range and a tie.
There's not gonna be any wording for this
in the paper or in the working draft.
No, because again, we're lazy and we had
like to have magical blanket wording.
That means we don't have to
repeat things over and over.
So we have.
Magic warning in the algorithms
requirements again that say that
range algorithms to take a range
are equivalent to the taking the
result of calling begin and end
on the range and passing it to
the iterator signal overload.
So now we'll look at this and make
sure that that's what it does.
Luckily, we don't need the
any kind of verification.
The major advantage, one of the
many advantages of ranges is that.
They are correct by construction, right?
Somebody passed in a range.
We don't need to worry about
mismatching begin and end.
Units indicating where that range
lies straight out of the range itself.
So we're pulling first out.
Of that range with ranges begin.
OK, yeah. Going out first.
And then we're going to call
the same iota unchecked,
with the result of unwrapping first.
And calling to the UN range.
You end is a magic accessor that
basically does the unwrapping for
us of getting the end of the range.
It's sometimes more efficient.
It's for a. Range types that
are implemented specifically to
have access to an unchecked end,
which is the thing in our design.
This will grab it directly instead of
calling in and then unwrapping the iterator.
It may be more efficient.
So we're taking those.
We're passing 3 arguments to
iota and checked, which doesn't.
We already know that it does.
It returns the final value of first,
which we wrap back up.
Iterator that we have and we
return the first move out just
as we did on the other overload.
So this is correct.
Can be implemented a little more
efficiently using rewrap iterator.
We have a helper.
Lots and lots of helpers.
This is probably an ex util.
Yes.
Crap. You gotta turn off related matches.
It is the. Dumbest feature
no you so so frustrating.
I guess if you don't remember what
you're looking for, it could be handy.
You know, if it's something like
this then then I might use that tool,
but when I know exactly what
I'm looking for there anyway,
we have a utility called rewrap iterator.
That takes a range and an unwrapped iterator.
And it will you either.
Sorry if the unwrapped iterator type is
the same as the wrapped iterator type.
That's what this is trying to say.
Right, if this unwrapped iterator type,
IT is the same as the actual
iterator type of the range.
Then we don't need to do anything funny
in reader app, we just return it.
If the unwrapped and wraps types
are different, this meaning this is
arranged that has checked iterators.
Then we'll go ahead and grab
a new begin from the range.
And we'll wrap up our.
Unwrapped iterator inside that and return it.
This is constrained to we're only work
with forward ranges and necessity
because you're only allowed to call
begin once on a single pass range.
Like calling began on an input range
or an output range can suck the
magic smoke out of it and make you
unable to call again on that again.
Since this takes an. Output range range.
It may be single pass.
And that means we can't
really use rewrap iterator.
We don't have any facility for.
Yeah, we're dealing with that.
Unfortunately.
So if we if we tried to it
would but fail to compile,
but only if our test coverage calls
it with an actual output only range.
Is that correct, yes.
OK, yeah it will fail to compile but
only when called with us sub forward.
Single pass range.
And to check my understanding,
because I I hit actually hadn't
looked into this commentary,
I was like, oh crap, iterator.
That sounds good because
I hadn't used it myself.
Even in the case where we
do have like a strong,
you know forward range in this code,
we need to start off by calling
ranges begin and then unwrap it.
I guess we could call you begin,
I suppose, but that's what we would do.
We would call you, but again,
I see you again, OK,
checked right into.
Drink, drink,
wrap with the idea idea that it doesn't
necessarily even need to keep first
around if they're the same iterator types,
for example.
Right and not a use after move.
I guess it's not.
I guess first is technically
it is a used after move,
yes?
OK, but are we like asserting that
this must be OK for anything that
deals with our OK use after move?
OK,
it's it's part of the design of the
iterator in wrapping design that.
Seek rap.
Seek wrapped could take can have a
a boot from and put it right here.
OK cool.
OK, yeah, essentially the the wrap
state has not been changed the
like the pointer to the parent
but the printer to the element is
what's getting totally reset here.
But I was wondering like I see what
that would do for like a forward
list or a stood list for vector.
Though it seems like we would
actually be calling begin twice.
Ohh no, not if we called
you begin to begin with.
We would at most have one begin.
OK, never mind, only the
single pass thing is preventing
this from being desirable.
Obviously you could sandwich something
together with the concept we're here.
But it's probably more
trouble than it's worth.
We're talking about a pretty
minimal benefit in the first place.
Let's go ahead and say I
don't think it's worth.
2. If constant.
And sub.
Separately, I don't know spell
that word. I believe this as is.
Well, no. Somebody say something.
Am I not? Am I dropping again?
No, you're fine.
It just looked like GitHub took
a little second to respond there,
possibly because you just
pushed a comment with a typo.
Because what I pushed comma of the typo.
Yeah, you're you're separately, you didn't.
You didn't fix it before submitting.
It's like my eyebrows twitching.
I'm like no, never,
never mind, it doesn't matter.
Uh.
Spell constant progressively.
OK, yeah, separately should be
designed to be spelled correctly.
It took three seconds and I realized
nobody had said anything for 10
seconds and thought that it was
disconnecting it again. Anyone?
OK, let's take deep breaths.
Everything's fine.
We are through iota.
I should verify.
This new indiff comment matches.
And if comment. If.
Has 23 and CPP Lib concepts is defined.
Yes. That's also correct,
because this is a C + + 23 EDITION.
And we don't want.
To define it that code and or
test it when we're running,
EG in a test suite.
Because EDG concept support
is still not quite ready.
For the STL, although it works well enough
that it's been enabled in Intellisense.
So Intellisense does see all
the concepts code in the SDL.
OK. Moving on to algorithm.
Sungard, which is again
right for the same reasons.
OK, let's slide down to.
Again, the public interface.
Definitions we've got the
neighborhood comment.
Recall we, so we don't
need to worry about that.
Where in the paper go?
Shift left and shift right.
Oh, this is weird.
Whatever we used to write,
the paper has kept the enormous
margins on my narrow window.
Which makes it pretty hard to read.
Anyway, uh. This is the template.
It takes. A first argument.
Must satisfy permutable and the
second must be a symbol for the 1st.
Which is exactly what this says.
Most explorer returning a sub
range of the first parameter.
Shift right?
First template parameter named first.
Second template parameter named last.
And inter difference tea.
Of the iterator type.
All right, this person is using it or gift.
Which is an internal thing we had
even before it was added in C + + 20.
That does effectively the same thing,
but by going through iterator
traits in subsec plus 20 mode
and by going through the actual
difference T alias in C + + 20 bug.
Yeah, I think if I recall.
Let's go ahead already. Comment on that.
But I don't see it. Is this above? Yes.
Miss go common in the first
occurrence and Stephen pointed
out that there were several,
so this is already taken care of alright?
Somebody already caught the
utter difference to issue.
I won't come on it on it again.
That probably came from copying our C-17.
Implementations of these
algorithms in the 1st place,
at least that that name pause to shift,
seems really familiar to me.
I'm glad that's Misco caught it cause
I probably would have missed that one.
I do know enough about like remove
CVT that if I see the ugly one being
used in modern code I'm like ohh we
can unconditionally is the modern one
but with iterative I think if Misco
hadn't noticed I probably would say
yeah I know what that does that looks
right and wouldn't have realized
oh we should just unconditionally
use the standard one there.
So I'm very glad you noticed it.
It's correct right?
It would have been correct.
Again it does the same thing.
It's was funny, but it's just a readability.
Problem only.
You know it's not. Look at the other.
Template forward range. Requires
that the iterator type is permutable.
We're returning a borrowed
subrange of that range shift left.
Takes the range argument
by forwarding reference.
And it also takes a range difference T
which is spelled correctly here because
we don't have another version of that.
And at the same.
Thanks parameter name positive shift.
So let's go ahead and look
at what these are doing.
This looks strangely similar to
the iota thing in that it's.
Checking the range right,
doing the validation first
of the range. And then.
Auto result equals first.
I'm sure that should mean something to me.
Let's go back and find this.
OK preconditions. Zero is true.
Effects, if it is zero or it is
greater than or equal to last minus
first right if N is greater than
a number of elements in the range.
What that means. It does nothing.
Hmm.
Returned to find something called last.
Your turn at first comma, new last for
the overloads and namespace ranges.
So we need to make sure that this.
Is the unmodified. First argument.
OK. And we do that by making a copy.
To rewrap alright, this is this
is clear to me and we're making a
copy of first we're unwrapping.
There's no move here,
so let's make sure this is.
Yeah, Permutable refines forward.
No, it's OK that we're not moving
first when we pass it to get unwrapped.
Which should leave it unmodified.
And we're going to wrap the return value
in this company we've made called result.
So hopefully with the return value from
shift left unchecked is going to be.
This new last that the paper says
it's calculating, which is the.
Well, whenever that pointer, sorry,
the iterator after the final L element
that was that contains a value that
was in the original range, right?
We're gonna ignore the the tail
of elements after that that are
going to be moved from when we
shift all the elements to the left.
So we checked this already, right?
It's unwrapping first unwrapping
last and passing pause to shift
left unchecked, let's go take a
look at that unchecked algorithm.
Which I'm certain was defined above here.
Is that against our style?
Yeah, it takes an iterator and a
Sentinel returns the iterator type.
Doesn't need to modify the synth and all.
Again, this needs to be utter difference T.
And its behavior is.
We're shifting by less than 0.
We advance first to the end of the ring,
the original range, and return it.
And that is going to be first plus.
The original number of elements in the range.
Minus. Zero, right?
If it is zero, then we that's
number of elements minus zero.
So new last will actually be the
iterator that corresponds to.
The Sentinel last.
And that's what we're doing.
We're advancing first until it's.
Proventil ask we're trying.
Otherwise, we want to start at first.
You did only equals zero, this is.
Interesting.
I think.
I thought there was a change.
To allow negative N.
With no effect. Or maybe the paper?
Sorry, May actually maybe shift
originally allowed negative end
with no effect. In the chain,
which was to make it a precondition.
You go look at what the standard says.
Or
the existing shift left of C + + 17
shift lock items? Yeah, precondition.
So this was not an error in
the context cited in the paper.
That's what the paper says.
So yeah, that must have originally
allowed in negative values,
and it was later changed my elegy issue,
and I got the order.
Mixed up in my memory.
Alright, I I won't argue
with Stephen's comment.
This is reasonable.
And if anything.
If you do and I agree we should.
The assertion. Sure.
No shift left itself.
Should be in the call or
instead of in this helper.
Easier for users. Yes, we report
errors inside something with a name
that they called in their code.
Which is probably obvious to Stefan
and obvious to me, but may not be
obvious to the person that wrote this,
so we'll include that comment.
We would need two assertions right for the
Iterator Sentinel and the ranges form.
I think. Is that right? Yes.
Did we do that elsewhere?
Where we repeat the assertions
in each public entry?
Rather than centralized or does it?
Has it not just come up with enough
that we've got preconditions?
I think we'd usually do that.
Yes, we usually apply preconditions
as close as we can to users.
OK, I couldn't remember,
uh, what we do.
If we don't, we should fix it.
I think I I think we may have some
cases where we do centralized,
but we're careful that the I think
we're called the message will
sometimes mention the the standard
pretty name rather than the under
score ugly name and say range is
double colon shift left requires blah,
even if it's being emitted
within the internal helper.
But I would need to go check to
see what the actual precedent is.
I believe we should not do
anything here except checking
that it's I can't see the code.
Can't see the forest for the trees OK?
We make a copy of first.
If we have a size Sentinel.
Recheck that positive shift if
positive shift is greater than.
Yeah, again, the entire
length of the input range,
and if so. We return first.
Which is correct?
Now do last would be, I lost the definition.
I still looking at shift left.
Now I'm looking at shift right.
Alright, you asked.
It's first plus the number of elements
in the range might have sets OK.
Except end caps. Effectively.
At last, minus first.
So if N is larger than last minus first.
Then we return the new last is just first,
which would be the result of
doing all this math. If this was.
Max of N and last months.
OK, so that's correct.
If it's seasonal, 4 if that's not greater,
we advance start at.
I paused to shift. Will you skip over?
You take this copy of first and we
skip over the the first N elements.
Now that we know that N is somewhere within.
The the range. This is gonna give
us a a copy from the point right?
We're gonna end up copying
from here into first later on.
OK, otherwise if we don't
have a size Sentinel.
You're going to start.
We're going to. Index our way into the range
manually instead of calling it advance.
Decorate pasta shift and for each
decrement. Will increment start at.
But not if it's already
at the end of the range.
If it has hit the end of the range.
You returned first.
Which we already decided
was the right thing, right?
If the shift count was greater
than the length of the range,
they should return first.
This is just another way to do it.
We try to avoid the other conditionals.
And I've afflicted miscall
with my hatred of multiple.
Blank lines, I know.
He just doesn't like this blank
line in between that. If constexpr,
the definition of the variable.
I believe you should not do
anything here except checking the
distance fire ranges distance.
This difference is less than 0.
It's less than zero.
We we have a problem.
If it's zero this does nothing.
Just familiarize yourself with debuggers.
Usually we use an internal helper
function for both implementations.
Without the balance checks.
But here the implementation might
be simple enough to do it in line.
All right, I'm not sure.
Entirely what he's talking about.
I do see.
What if we could use the three
argument form of ranges advance here?
There's a form of ranges advanced that
takes an iterator account and a Sentinel.
It tries to advance the
iterator count steps and stops
if it reaches Sentinel before.
Going count steps.
I think that's how I would do this.
Because I could get under who?
Yes, I, I wonder if it would result in the
same behavior when you do reach that last,
because here it looks like we need to return
the first iterator if the user has asked
for an unreasonably large pause to shift.
But if we use the three Arg
clamped version of ranges advance,
I think we might not end up returning first.
I could be wrong though.
I haven't traced through all the logic.
And with the Miscoe suggestion
to use move unchecked,
I also am not sure exactly what it means
now that you've pointed it out. Yeah,
because there's no like move unchecked in.
We're trying to find the specific
iterator in the middle.
Unchecked, yeah, we do call it there,
so I'm not sure what the suggestion is.
Oh, and time check it has been one hour
and 31 minutes ohpa time check already.
Oh, this is so much fun. OK.
The nice thing about the three argument
range is advanced is it returns.
Uh, you know count that's leftover.
So if there is a nonzero if it returns
nonzero, we could return first.
As we're advancing whatever is start at,
we will advance, start at by pasta,
shift towards last.
So it would work here.
I don't know if it's better or
not without thinking about it,
and we've run out of time
for thinking about it.
Unfortunately, so why don't we
go ahead and knock off here?
Yeah, it'll take at least another
15 minutes to finish shift left.
So we're going to go ahead and stop,
apologize for starting a little bit late.
We might have been able to get to the
end of it if we had that 5 minutes back.
Sorry I haven't used this particular machine.
I haven't driven here before,
so I wasn't set up and prepared.
Anyway, let's, uh go to questions.
Are there any questions in the chat?
Has everybody been asking?
No outstanding questions,
just some talk about, uh.
Why are we using those neighborhoods
and the stood move optimization?
So you, you've already covered everything.
Ohh, there's a suggestion from
Cameron that we assign our suggestion.
Our suggestion to him to implement
movement compiler funding.
Anyway, OK. Thank you all for coming.
And I actually like the live
question format better than people
type things in chat and having
to go back and get them later.
It worked well. Yeah thanks.
I will stop the recording now.